hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
with no clips so here's some perfect BS
from CNN Scott yeah
um we don't know each other but speaking
on behalf of millions of American
parents I have four at home
I had to teach them at home my wife had
to teach them at home
I am stunned at what you have said this
week
about
you're claiming to have
wanted to reopen schools I think most
you'll find that most parents believe
you were the tip of the Spear of school
closures there are numerous statements
you made over the summer of 20 scaring
people to death about the possibility of
opening schools and I Hear No Remorse
whatsoever about the generational damage
that's been done to these guys I have
two kids with learning differences do
you know how hard it is for them to
learn at home and not in a classroom
that was designed for them and for you
to sit in front of Congress and the
American people and say
oh I wanted to open them the whole time
I am shocked I'm stunned I'm stunned and
there are millions of parents who feel
the exact same way okay go ahead
so
I don't know you sir and you don't know
me
but I have worked for the last 20 or 30
years helping kids every single day I've
been a schoolteacher
I've been a union leader
I knew and understood the importance of
reopening schools and the importance of
making sure that people were safe and
poll after poll that we did of parents
and I spent a lot of time with parents
said that they basically understood and
supported that we needed to do both I'm
really sorry I think parents wanted to
keep the kids nobody wanted to parents
nobody wanted to keep kids why did we
fail how did Europe
and the rest of the Civilized World get
this right and we failed they had the
how did they how did the schools the
schools in Europe that opened sooner
than we did and most of them did had the
mitigating Circumstances had the
mitigating strategies that we were just
talking about and it wasn't negotiable
it wasn't oh well it's inconvenient to
have six feet or it's inconvenient to
have mass they had these things and the
other thing they did and I don't know if
it was right or wrong the other thing
they did is they prioritized schools
over commerce they prioritize schools
over bars and restaurants and things
like that